new rule now that Kim jong-un has
executed some 70 officials he has to
explain why his barber is still alive is
it possible he's surrounded by
sycophants so many sick of vans that
nobody has the nerve to tell him his
hair looks ridiculous yes I suppose that
is possible
new rule Columbia house the 13 albums
for $1 people must not be allowed to
file for bankruptcy as they did this
week they must be charged with crimes
against humanity who will speak for the
millions were forced to by Spandau
Ballet men at work at Laura Branigan
albums they did not want or that Bruce
Willis Bruno album and who will hold to
account the company that invented the
long term contract you can never get out
of before Verizon and Comcast perfected
it new rule Gwyneth Paltrow has to
answer this question are you trying to
make us hate you this week winneth spoke
about GMO labeling on Capitol Hill but
when it was Senator Leahy's turned to
speak she started texting you know if
this keeps up you're going to ruin the
end of the movie 7 because when the
audience finds out it's your head in the
box
they're just going to go good oh sorry
spoiler alert
you're all now that the thing we used to
use to phone each other is being used
for everything but phoning each other we
must stop calling it a phone it's time
to call these things what they really
are
food cameras and douche bag locators and
a related new rule just so we're clear
if you look directly at me and speak and
then when I reply you point to your
headset to indicate you're actually
talking to someone else on the phone
you're the [ __ ]
you